welcome to this video playing
international master Providence from the
US John Bryant john bryant cgm now no
that's no sorry this is brian smith this
and he is GM now sorry yeah this is a
this is a good I am though it's got a
very decent five-minute rating here yeah
this is a funny line that is quite
interesting by developed by David
Bronstein there is a line where white
sacrifice appears as well now i cannot
remember I just have to just have to
bring at him normally playing with them
well based on good values it's not bad
development centralization I'm trying
that just developing things castles
rupee eight hoping for temple gains on
his screen for example you cannot take
twice rupee eight wins the Queen and if
he moves castles yeah then I have them
we should reform I have to shirdi for
him anyway should I do that I mean he
does not really have a great great
square for the Queen this looks like a
disaster actually a little bit okay can
go there i was thinking Queen d2 III
which is a disaster but what about this
there's some way now to break through
his King
something like III on
yeah ah difficult Casey three and one
pawn down in this position
definitely for compensation but it's um
it's it's difficult very difficult to
play I try to to open up now with b5 it
takes Knight takes I'm on from Knight
takes you three 92 is probably what you
should do I think one problem is C
cannot easily castle here so do i play a
5a for this kind of thing on just takes
if i take it his Queen Queen gets into
play which is really not what I want
okay maybe this is a bit of a general
move but and now we can castle and do I
go a for now or not this kind of thing
yeah he's definitely in the game now I
probably have spoiled my chances
somewhat okay
ah now it was it was very tricky to play
for both sides
hmm really c5 surprised me maybe it's
okay but I was really more expect him in
to take
94 I will just take c5 I guess takes d6
I take on b3 and that cannot be really
great for white went to that words that
would be surprising ok so here I just go
to should be five and now a 3 just
ripping it open as far as possible so
that i can take on c3 now is this is a
good attack not sure about the objective
merit that it is dangerous in any case
ok ok I can take g5 of course but this
is taking the base of this pawn look
some look Sam looks looks good ok taking
see for the hand come on take it Quincy
for I can take I cannot sacrifice the
Queen can I probably not um a check or
Queenie five min not sure
if i get my bishop to play somehow it
would be great but it does not look very
likely maybe c64 95 so that the night is
joining so 95 96 maybe
okay i'm covering that i also have look
b8 the knight on d4 is not defending
before any more oh wow just to text this
hmm
it's probably not the best way to go
time warning they had to play hoops I
had to play with us this is hanging
actually now check so do this right if I
if this was my idea for Knight c3 and
and things like that I cannot take what
is Knight c3 doing really and how did he
manage to get ahead on the clock these
kind of things I really like to know
sometimes when I was in total command
clockwise it was really ahead on the
clock
and I'd be a gem ah God
check check I can go to be three okay
maybe I'm prove I'm promoting now check
I can just take it and I have no time
Wow yeah I was a super crazy game I
really thought I mean this this cannot
be really grateful I am cannot you
whatever you do you cannot convince me
that this should be any good for wine
okay with this lead in development and
then things but it is it is super murky
yeah b5 I mean at one point I must have
had a good position I'm absolutely not
believing that this round here that I'm
not good takes a 383 before how do I win
now Bishop see three wins but how
exactly why the check and 95 I mean I'm
am I blind or something I mean SS this
is like I mean I don't have a dog but if
I had one it probably would find it
mobile I mean this is like front of the
kids right come on I mean okay this is
probably still good around here look at
the eight stronger it's all like minus
two and then things here even here even
here just totally okay I just should
just I mean I really didn't think that
the apron would be any dangerous
dangerous but it was the computer just
says I should take and have a clear head
I mean okay I've got a point for the
exchange his king is wide open yeah it
does make some sense of course but I
totally underestimated that the pawn is
so dangerous I was just thinking okay
I'm I'm active and everything but the
corn round here it's unstoppable yeah
and it's very easy i just pushes the
pawn i mean very easy to play ignoring
the rest of it so what is it what i
should do after a six queen to be eight
hmm it stops a seven that much is clear
yeah but this is useless ready to
analyze I mean I just I just win here if
I if I go if I favor this is just just
just a complete win and very very much
the consequence of this this stuff what
is this night here and everything's week
and so on stretching a porn here which
opens up the whole position and so on I
mean there should be some punishment for
that but well if I overlook this this
kind of simple stuff you can play
anything oh wow thanks for watching